welcome to this video
round five Rapha candidates and we are
carrying crown link against Aronian the
two pre-tournament favourites by most
experts and yeah obviously very
important game they're both on plus one
have won a game and in case of aruna he
won two games but lost one so they have
the same score they are trading are not
buy one win and this game is obviously
very important and this is not just
because of the point that is distributed
in the game itself it's also to be noted
that the tiebreak in case of two players
being on equal points after the 40
rounds the first tiebreaker is the
individual score between them so if you
look at the round one win of Anand it
was very important that he be Tyrone yet
so if he will be on even points with
Aronian at the end he has very good
shots is to have the better tie
breakdown so this is a kind of yeah
point with with an extra so very
important game so let's see what happens
from Lee playing d4 not a surprise there
he's mixing within the closed games d4
c4 Knight e3 but d4 the most freakin
move and Aronian is going for this move
order he's ready to play the
nimzo-indian I'd see three but chronic
playing Knight f3 and here Iranian
usually placed the Queen's Gambit which
he does here he only rarely employs the
Queen's in you know other defenses g5
this is main main weapon for while he
was also employing them this moves water
to get to the Queen's Gambit but he had
suffered some defeats in this line so he
avoids that now with the
at night f66 move water okay d5 and tyr
Kramnik has a choice of course very
often you play two g3 which with much
success but this is very much a
theoretical method round now with long
lines and Knight c3 yeah the big issue
is that if you go for a Queen's Gambit
main line like that there are lines like
the Laska where very often pieces are
traded quickly and it can fizzle out to
a draw what is chronic doing is played
III quite a surprise it's not the most
common move but in a way it looks
passive because it keeps this Bishop
locked in but in some way it is one of
the more aggressive moves and this is
because the long theoretical lines that
might trade off pieces are not possible
here why does developing anymore yeah
more slow fashion but at the same time
he avoids any early simplifications and
we see that his development plan has
some bite to it
aronia played b6 relatively quickly so
he was not completely taken aback by
that
b6 Knight c3 Bishop d7 this makes lots
of sense black is putting this bishop on
the long diagonal and therefore trying
to address his standard problem in the
Queens gambit declined quickly the
bishop on c8 this position that we have
now on the board is in fact quite often
arising from a Queen's Indian moves
order so something like like that this
is the way it is reached quite quite
more often okay so what is Kramnik doing
now is exchanging on d5 this is some may
be somewhat strange looking because why
would white take on d5 exactly now yeah
the thing is in this
black guys recapturing with the pawn if
he takes with the night at some point
white will prepare for a form and this
is very much similar to the Queen's
Indian the Trojan where white has not
played a3 so he's almost a tempo up not
so great black wants to take with with
the pawn and this way why just reached
the structure where he enjoys an extra
pawn in the center so good central
control and long-term he has two basic
plans he can try to push a four because
Jack look at this after this the check
he is provoking c6 ESL c6 Bishop b3 one
plan is a form this was why the check
was inserted so that with c6 black is
blocking a bit of this Bishop stir
agonal for example this type of efore
push can become very relevant if black
is developing with Bishop d6 I can I can
show you an example Aronian is playing
Bishop e7 if he plays Bishop d6 which
looks more natural then he must be ready
for this type of type of push here the
bishop is not so great on d6 black would
very much prefer to have it only 7 to
have more cover for the King side
why does slightly more comfortable him
he played Bishop e7 to be more
effectively placed against the you for
idea so castles castles and now b3 yeah
White is going to fianchetto and the big
idea in the long run for white is to put
a knight on e5 and supported possibly
with f4 this is also right after Knight
bd7 and Bishop b2 a popular move here
this has been played for a number of
times the popular move here is to move
Bishop d6 for example this has been
played by
hop off in in one of one important game
and the candidates match in the 90s
against Gelfand yeah but should be six
very logical move it just covers a five
so that 95 is simply losing a pawn um
and this makes it more difficult for
whites to to follow up with this idea
with 95 right very often continues in
entirely different fashion now one idea
is this regrouping intending Knight f5
and maybe in the long run prepare for
something in the center note that a very
important feature of this position is
there are all pieces on the board it
will it will become an interesting
flight only later it's not a direct
clash but when when both forces actually
meet they still have let's say all their
troops together and it's not as it is
and let's say the last guy variation of
the Queen's Gambit where you trade off
piece after piece after piece and easily
yet it fizzles out to a draw so this
also would have been an interesting
choice but Aronian played rook e8 and
this almost invites 95 so he's ready for
the sharp better with the knight on e5
cronic is going for that there should be
six now and f4 this is what Aronian
could have prevented but it seems that
he's not afraid of the situation and
actually welcomes that the the whole
battle is sharpening up now yeah why is
it sharpening up well this is a strong
piece on e5 and black cannot take it
ever because of the four camp cannot
ever take it it's forking pieces and
it's very difficult to get rid of this
piece so is it just bad for black no it
isn't black has counter play and this is
because if row is also a weak spot he
will get counter play on this Square and
yeah this means that's a sharp metal
coming especially considering how many
of white pieces have
that's draw the sinew how many of white
pieces are actually pointing towards the
king side even the bishop here white can
easily you give to get the Queen into
the play they look into the play
so everything that Weis has is geared
towards blacks King so when a crisis is
very much likely to happen soon after
FYE played c5 really quickly it's hard
to play without c5 so very logical move
and chronic played Queen to f3 also very
standard in this position type to cover
a four so 94 is not easily possible now
yeah what should like do here aronia I
think is playing a very logical manner
he took on d4 and then played Bishop to
b4 and this I like very much because
black and blacks play is very
straightforward what he what do you
thinks is okay
he form is my spot for counter play and
I'm not able to go there at the moment
if you look at this White has protected
everything nicely and wins upon so he is
just playing Bishop before possibly
intending just to take here and plant
this knight on e4 why not this is a very
good spot for the piece and whiter wants
to avoid that place 92 and the knight is
heading over to the Kings side anywhere
anyway where it is a very useful form
for the check on the King yeah but now
after 92 like can play Knight e4 it is
nicely protected now the e4 square so
you can centralize the night yeah and
what black is in a way banking on or
hoping for is that the night only 4 is
really a piece that cannot be attacked
by a pawn anymore as the d4 + f4 set up
this kind of Stonewall setup has
weakened deform and
like actually kemplay f6 at some point
to make sure that the knight on e5 has
to leave for its master exchange itself
yeah so this is what black is hoping for
the good structure a3 was played now and
yeah well here we need to briefly check
what about 92 is this a nice
yeah it's a really greedy to smooth and
in fact if you analyze it a bit you'll
find out that this is not working at all
Whitehead has two very good replies one
is Bishop h7 kind of a fleshie way to
play like that check check
yeah now why does the good show us can
move the rook or just take here
something like that is it's not going to
end well White has even extra material
and still a great attack and on top of
all of that after 92 white can also play
the very simple move Queen h3 and win it
in a very simple fashion attacking h7
and now before is also hanging something
like that it's check entirely unplayable
it's not even a material problem for
white besides the overwhelming attack
yeah 92 is not on at all he played
Bishop to f8 and yeah where else the
bishop is nice on f8 to defend now
rookie 192 at some point is a threat so
rook t1 makes lots of sense yeah now
Aronian is playing the move a six yeah
an interesting point here's if you want
a small tactical exercise what does
happen after the move f6 um which
already described as being one of Plex
main ideas for for getting counter play
getting rid of the knight on e5 yeah
treat this this is an exercise I'll be
silent for a couple of seconds so that
you can pause the video white to play
here and what is he able to do
alright I'll show you the move now white
wins with the move Queen takes info it's
quite quite funny yeah okay if you take
the Queen this Bishop c4 check and we
see that this is diagonal it's
enormously weakened and following this
line it's quite funny how many pieces
White is winning this night is just
winning two minor pieces and of course
with it the game always check so very
very funny sequence f6 was simply a
would have been a huge blunder
okay Aronian obviously didn't fall for
that he played a6 which is multi-purpose
move yeah the most important things it
does is it prepares b5 also giving some
room for the Queen yeah and it prevents
any possible Bishop b5 moves so the good
move from [ __ ] playing a4 he wants to
prevent b5 for the time being
rook c8 yeah useful putting the look on
a half-open file black is simply relying
on the solidity of his position he has
not weakened anything on the King side
so it's unlikely that white should have
something yeah brilliant
coming up but it's still there are lots
of pieces that are near like skiing or
nearing blacks King Queen h5 this is
very very important in order to get
anywhere they need to be some kind of
problems on the Kings side so white is
provoking that by attacking on f7 g6
must be played and now Knight h3
attacking the knight on this
yeah at Aronian I think again chooses
the the sharpest continuation here he
plays Knight d2 f6 it's probably okay
yeah but I mean all with the grain or
difficult to tell because it's a such a
complicated position there was some
simpler alternative but also has
mentioned less sharp he also could have
played f5 I don't really think there's
something entirely wrong with this idea
on the other hand it's of course and
move that yeah it's in a way not very
ambitious black is just yeah trying to
close the position as much as possible
but it doesn't seem to be bad really I
don't I don't think that white is
anything greater if he tries form
something very direct with g4 this
Knight takes e5 after which this capture
is probably not too great because of
Queen g5 after D takes the our black has
this check check coming and I don't know
this seems entirely unclear to me if you
look at this let's say king over LSD for
coming and yeah I don't know I don't
really see anything wrong with that five
but Aronian smooth front is probably all
right as well it's it's the sharper move
because long term you still have this f6
idea and yeah
white is not like winning instantly so
why not play that d f6 yeah and that
chronic is pushing is going for f5 you
need to get something going here
right here and the knight to g3 might
attack the e4 outposts you need to open
up something and f5 is the logical move
yeah here there are the first direct
ways black can go wrong I mean
just to show how dangerous the position
really is let's start first with
huronian played he played g5 you know um
keeping it as close as possible and this
seems to be all right um there was an
alternative defense rook c7 to cover the
seventh rank this also seems to be okay
but move like Bishop g7 which looks
completely normal can actually lead to
some some serious problems already if we
look at this if white takes now on e4
and black recaptures with the pawn yeah
you need to do that this is not possible
at all something like that leads to yeah
absolute disaster Jack Black is not
going going to survive that so needs to
take with the pawn and after that White
has various dangerous attacking
possibilities one is to sacrifice on f7
or even d5 yeah intending to sacrifice
on f7 and this can can easily lead to a
quick defeat to something like that and
and that's it why does white is winning
already this is not playable at all
Queen takes Czech loses the Queen to
this discover check and Bishop takes
check you're not going to survive as
well look at this threatening g7 it's
just just a complete disaster
yeah why the tech is dangerous black
must be must be really alert iam Bishop
g7 has mentioned normal looking but
problem yeah he played g5 has mentioned
try to keep it closer the F file and
this seems to be an okay defense okay
Nagi three very logical this Knight
needs to needs to be attacked
it's the the cornerstone of blacks
defense
yeah aronia now played the move b5 I
like it it's a good active defense it
gets the Queen into play and disturbs
white a bit on the Queen side if you
look at alternatives just to show how
danger it is already how dangerous it
already is if black takes for example
and tries to cover here white just plays
h4 with an attack it's already almost
too much from like if you do something
like that this is an additional
attacking motif and white white would
win here simply on g5 yeah it's really
it's really difficult to play
I like b5 I think Aronian I think
defends excellently b5 yeah what should
why do I guess taking is the best move
this is what chromic did and now Queen
to b6 yeah here an interesting and
interesting moment of the game kramnik
now played the move King to h1
after a couple of minutes of
consideration and I think this is a good
move really he also could have tried to
keep a pawn here I mean black is
sacrificing a pawn actually but I don't
I don't really like it it's um it's not
so great in terms of the initiative if
white takes we can consider that if Y
takes on a6 and black recaptures one of
blacks ideas to exchange off the
somewhat passive b7 bishops for the d3
bishop and at the end have this strong
knight on e4 in this in this line White
has some attacking ideas as well but I
don't I don't know how good it really is
I mean white can take on e4 and this is
an interesting line in fact one reason
being that the capture with the pawn is
not not really great because of this and
Queen g3 this is again a very very
dangerous attack that black is probably
not going to survive but there is 94 of
course this is this capture and here
it's it's it's really crazy the greatest
thing is that white can play both 97 all
night f7 all night f7 black actually has
as a funny way to defend she can take on
d3 rook takes and then rooks e7 which
looks completely bonkers but hits really
good tonight has no square to go to it's
quite funny as Knight e5 is answered by
simply the capture and this is why
chronic played King edge won this type
of IDM and here this seems completely
unclear white can can take here and now
we have three pawns for the piece but
it's not really a convincing yeah and
well this is another idea that white can
try Queen d6 and then possibly yeah no
more than one possible there's also f6
here I just noticed that also
interesting now but it amounts to the
same something like that it's probably
going to going to happen and I'm not so
sure how much this type of position
really promises wide this is fantastic
night it's just great and what is this
Bishop doing oops
yeah it's this bishop what is this
Bishop doing I mean this position were
probably quite good for black if it
weren't for the pawn on d5 which always
you know means that black must be
cautious yeah why it's extra pawn on b3
is meaningless yeah I don't know and in
this this this kept only six
it feels like it's conceding some of
whites initiative it's just not really
yeah focused on
taking this B takes a6 King h1 I really
like it's a good human decision you want
to attack here and not grab a pawn so
black will be captured and after that
Bishop takes e4 was played this also was
chrome next idea when you played King h1
and there were alternatives of course
white can also try moves like Knight h5
and they also need to interesting play
but I think Bishop before is really the
move that sets the most problems for
black and therefore it's the best move
an easy variation to calculate as Knight
takes e4 this is not playable at all
because of oops of this winning
instantly it's just the Queen breaking
through on h7 something like that check
it's an absolute disaster
yeah black must take with the pawn it's
here must take with the pawn
there's no alternative and now chrome
makes a big point he's playing d5 and
this is exactly while king h1 this
entire concept was really strong look at
this you needed to do that otherwise
it's simply not possible to push the
pawn and this is now a really really
dangerous attacking position because the
bishop is opened up the sleeping bishop
on b2 now gets to be a very very good
piece and black in fact cannot take on
d5 in any way if you take with the
bishop start with that white has yeah
even more than one good move but not g4
is very strong it is a double check on
f6 with a check and g5 hangs black only
can take and after this he threatens
Queen takes g5 winning and there's also
the bishop hanging so that's a complete
win very easy
and if he goes 95 and the easiest way
more than one way again but it's easiest
to just take this Bishop takes and 97
and well this will be a monstrous check
with Queen age 7 mate in the mix it's
just a complete win so black cannot take
the pawn so what should he do
Aronian played III cold-blooded defense
the best move again it's really up to
this point I guess almost perfectly
played by both players really great
really great and it introduces
counterclaim the active defense is the
best defense
yep ok chromic now play Knight g4 I
think this makes lots of sense this is
the defensive piece you need to exchange
um black took only move Queen takes and
h6
Queen takes g5 was the simple threat and
now the next move I think is also yeah
quite quite logical Knight e4 as sharp
as possible putting this Knight into the
attack and threatening Knight f6 yeah
and we see now that it's already a bit
difficult for black to defend with them
yeah let's say a passive means Fe em
tries to hold this possession position
together with something like let's say
Bishop g7 for example you can just take
here King takes and then f6 giant 95
will decide the issue
there's no way to to hold something like
that with me to come
black needs to do something creative now
and what what is the defense Aronian
plays a very strong move Roxie - the
only move but still still it is strong
yeah it's an active defense and it's all
based on a queen sacrifice after Knight
f6 of course black cannot move the King
it would lose everything you need to
sacrifice the Queen and this is what an
onion did he took on f6 Bishop cakes and
now he - we see that while doing that he
has kept a little bit of time on the
clock
Black has 25 minutes left so he's got
more time than cronic and after he -
here the game has reached his ultimate
crisis what is going on
very tricky okay black is walking oops
walking both works here so he's bound to
get some of the material back at the
moment he only has a bishop for the
Queen it's not like much and it's
White's move of course and young what is
the best move here in fact kramnik I
think played the best move he sacrificed
on g5 this bishop just to break through
immediately it's a it's not really
advisable to do anything slowly here
let's say let's say Bishop a1 just for
argument's sake black takes takes on d5
and now it's black with the attack yeah
now it's black with the attack if white
tries to cover that okay I'm going to
take here this is Eve no mate to
completely reverse roles here yeah you
must be really direct here white has
absolutely no time for slow moves Bishop
takes g5 must be played funny enough and
now crown nick has got some some time
here on the clock they probably had some
relay issues but it is clear that
Aronian had more time on the clock but
probably Kramnik
clock e'en on the Asus not so not so
precise yeah okay this is the position
of the game
what like place now is the only it's the
only mistake that here that he commits
in the whole game he plays Bishop takes
d5 and this actually should lose but we
see what what happens what like should
do actually is to really just take the
rook here check yeah like that and now
grab on g5 it turns out that if you
analyze that with the help of an engine
check that this position is really just
a draw I know it's probably a not so
it's it's probably hard to believe but
the computer is very insistent on this
beyond being a complete draw and after
looking at it for for a while
I'm pretty yeah I can agree with that I
mean I'm always skeptical about the
computer evolves and then you should be
I mean they're often enough problems
with them but here this really very very
concrete problem how is right going to
to attack here likes King you have the
problem that you cannot ever use the
rook because of a back rank made so
something like that of course that's the
void that you must play you can only
attack with the Queen and probably use
f6 if we analyze f6
for starters black is going here and
well he has this counter play against
the king and the g2 pawn white how is
white going to improve this position I
really don't see how you cannot move the
D pawn of course this would simply open
up this diagonal and how is why it's
ever going to get ahead here you can
play route sorry rook g1 to cover the
pawn but well like it's just staying on
the second rank
and if he gets Bishop takes d5 and he's
even better so why does probably advise
to just take the draw with this
perpetual check there is not there's
nothing more he must he must take the
draw but Aronian played Bishop takes d5
and I guess I'm not sure what exactly if
he did did overlook there but now in
this position Kramnik can win the game
he has in fact I believe yeah in fact
what he played seems to win as well but
there were there were clearer
alternatives the clearest win here is
Bishop e7 check which is of course
checking the King and what should like
play probably a king to h7 and is this
the best one but confusing myself no
Bishop g7 s actually actually the better
news yeah the point is that f6 is not
helping check yeah this is in fact okay
for black but what can I do
yeah white in this position um can
instead of playing f6 can go for well my
notes are real messy affair
they can play root G 1 this is the
important important point yeah the idea
being that if black now takes the rook 1
do you wanna just taking here with the
Queen and then d5 is hanging yeah and
here um black will lose more material he
does not have enough counter play he
cannot cover the bishop on g5 as this is
just protected and the relatively best
line is probably something like that
rook g2 Queen d5 chat something like
that and this is
after black loses the b-pawn this is
probably a relatively trivial win for
white yeah tough tough to calculate that
really there's also Bishop f6 check this
is this is the the problem of this
position and do you have many moves they
all look good but what exactly is the
best one yeah this is comparable
I think this seems to win as well quite
similar to the other line but here the
rook II form is a move that my turn
sorry check look II four is a move that
might irritate White Queen eeeh three
still seems to win but it looks awfully
complicated yeah those moves Bishop e7
check and the ship f6 check they it
seems that white was winning with that
but Bishop h6 what chronic plane is also
fine King age 7 and exactly here here's
the big spot and this might might be one
of the key spots of the whole tournament
very likely actually because both
players are very likely to be in
contention for the for the rest of until
the end for this desired first place
yeah here white chronic occurred have
won the game with rook g1 he said he
took but let's look at group g1 this we
already saw the idea this prophylactic
Kevin and it seems that after Bishop
takes aged six yeah that's that's the
toughest try this actually is relatively
easy and probably not what he had
overlooked attacking here attacking here
and this as well White is very easily
winning here
so it's probably Bishop h6 where he saw
the problem
rook D to e one and then black can still
hang on I mean it's not like black will
resigned the position but what what is
winning nevertheless here black can try
to hang on with moves like rookie five
or rupee for but in the long run
white white should win this at the
moment he looks a bit tied up but okay
it's a queen against two bishops and
white just needs to be a bit patient
here moves like h3 later Luke a one
group GE one yeah the thing is you you
have a really substantial material plus
already so you can quite often return
some material to to to clarify matters
yeah this is really a missed chance what
I actually believe is that that cronic
had calculated the line in the Game
Capture here and here rook g1 as we saw
was winning
I believe when I do believe is he
calculated the line that happened in the
game and he maybe had some some small um
yeah he didn't probably evaluate the
endgame right because what we see now is
a complete trade down to an ending he
took on f8 and now the next couple of
moves are completely forced like he
needs to get the rook back with a check
and now he took on g2 and he are white
now as this is threatening fantastic
discovery must give up the Queen Jack
completely forced and this rook endgame
at first sight I can easily believe that
chronic belief that he is winning here
because white has an extra pawn the H
palm and after king of three he's even
got the more active King so isn't wide
winning to be honest I'm not sure
I'm not sure when when I analyzed it
I couldn't find a win for white and in
in the game Kramnik he couldn't find a
win as well which is the far more the
far more reliable indication of course
I'm I'm really sure that me plus an
engine is we can't aim than chronic yeah
okay I really really can't tell if white
still has a win here but I doubt it
let's look at some concrete moves black
is of course getting the king near the
action and now activates the rook why it
has this active King it's it's hard to
believe but it seems that it's a it is
not enough he has to worry about the H
pawn the H porn cannot really be
promoted any time it's just useful to
have as a decoy but white really wants
to do is to get to the b-pawn without
giving up the F pawn this would be nice
but it's very hard to do that in the
game he got villa was he got close king
before and now it's very important the
next defensive setup that Aronian is
going from he plays rook c8 and this is
very important you shouldn't take the
pawn and give up the beep horn in a
situation where white keeps the F pawn
this is critical I mean I'm pretty sure
almost sure that it is lost even but he
defended much better
he played rook c8 note that rook h8 also
was last move before the chime control
rook c8 and now the Rick is blockading
the C file while the King is approaching
the F pawn and here I really don't know
how a white is going to get anywhere
here after age form he played the
Milwaukee aid which seems to be fine
another idea is here even before
intending looks III it's I mean if white
some some idea if he has some idea to
win it's really a matter of a very
subtle maneuvers because the
straightforward things simply don't work
if we look at this positioning with
before for example this counter play
with rooks III I couldn't I couldn't
find anything let's just play it out to
show the general idea yeah black is
trying to get the pawn it takes and now
the King takes f5 and it's simple as
that the F pawn is providing enough
counter play for example look here okay
h3 before look H 4 B 5 B 4 B 6 yeah and
now we send the 8th porn and at the end
we get this typical endgame some
something like that and black will
promote the pawn to to a draw and this
is the general drawing idea here to have
the end have the F pawn to to get the
counter play what Aronian is doing is
very very similar in playgroup e8 and
after king c5 check gave the check King
d6 it is very important that king c6 can
even be answered by rook takes a 5 as
this King and pawn endgame is wrong yeah
this is a drawn like a spooky enough was
with a spawn to secure the draw
yeah Kramnik went to d6 and now this is
the counter play it's quite similar to
what I shown with b4 roots III and it
leads to actually
checked the same situation with the
earth porn
getting getting on the way to to get the
counterplay you will he got this porn
here Zack
okay here that's absolutely no way for
why to make any headway check check
check
they really played it out to bear Kings
so a really a titanic struggle and a
great game a great game by both players
really it was a super complicated
positions really super complicated and
they only they only made like two
mistakes which is simply great here if
he go back to the critical moment Bishop
d5 was Rowan's only mistake in the game
really everything else was was a lot
great I think
and of course for Kramnik he could have
won with this rook g1 idea after this
check this or this or this like he
played check the only he only needs to
find rook g12 to win the game which
would have been of course huge huge in
the tournament it would have sent
kramnik 2+2 in the lead together with
Anand and Aronian back to 50% but as it
turned out with the draw the situation
has not changed fundamentally both
players are plus +1 and yeah in in good
shape and nevertheless I think this kind
of game proves that they really are
playing on an exceptionally high level
you cannot play a complicated position
like that without making any sort of
mistake so it's completely inappropriate
to say how they're blundered know that
they didn't it's just humans playing on
the exceptionally high level but you
cannot play
perfectly all right I hope you enjoyed
the game and yeah you'll join again to
tomorrow when coverage commences with
round six thanks for watching